كانوا يقعدو في عزين الشتاء يطلعونا من
المعتقل يحطوه على الارض وفي عزين ما هي
الدنيا بتشتي يحطوا روؤس نام غسو في
[موسيقى]
الارض انا بدي احكي لكم قصه كانت ايام
الاسر في البدايه انا كنت رايحه على الممر
الامن فهناك كانوا الجنود موجودين قالوا
لنا تعالوا انزلنا خلوا امي ست كبيره تروح
لحالها ونحن نزلونا على ثبت انه نلحقها
فقالوا لنا لا انتم انتم رهن الاعتقال
جابونا للتفتيش وللتحقيق هناك حققوا معنا
على الجبل عدوا يشتموا قعدوا يغلطوا عدوا
يقولوا لنا انه انه بتعرفوا حد في حماس
بتعرفوا انفاق بتعرفوا اي تعرفوا كاميرات
في الشوارع فاحن ما بنعرف شيء هذا الشيء
بخص حماس نحن ما بصنا فقالوا لنا لا انتم
لازم تعترفوا قعدنا تحت التهديد الضرب وال
والغلط لمده ثلاث ساعات من خلالها ما
اقتنعوا بالحكي اللي حكيناه فقالوا لنا
انتم حنوك رهن الاعتقال على السجن
تواخذونا على معتقل اسمه زكيم قعدونا هناك
ست ايام تعزيب جوع غلط نطلب الدوا ما فيش
نطلب اغراض ما فيش في السقعه نطلب بطانيات
نتدفى ما فيش كانوا كثير يعذبوا البنات
كانوا يشلحو يخلوا الجنود يتمسخروا عليهم
يتضح وقوا عليهم كان طريقه كثير عنيفه
كانوا يشلح البنات ب شالتهم ما يعطوهم
اياهم يطلبوه يترج جوهم يرجعوا لهم يبكوا
لهم ما كان حد يسمعهم كانوا يتمسخروا
عليهم الجنود ياخذوا الشالات منهم ويرمو
على الارض يقول لهم انتم هيك بتستحق زي ما
عملتوا فينا احن بدنا نعمل فيكم كانوا
يضربوهم ويعذبونهم اه يمسكوه في الباص
يحطوا راسنا في الارض بالبساط يدوسوا على
رجلينا يشرحوا بساطير يضربونا فيهم اه انا
اخذت هوايه منهم في
رجليه كانوا يقعدو في عزين الشتاء يطلعونا
من المعتقل يحطو على الارض وفي عزين ما هي
الدنيا بتشتي يحطوا رؤس نام غسو في الارض
كان عن جد الموقف صعب كثير لما نشوف بنات
شرفن وعرض بنهك من ورا شويه جنود اللي ما
علو شيء طلعوه بعد 50 يوم هيك عندهم
القانون فجوا قبلها بيوم قالوا لنا بدنا
نفرج عنكم وثاني يوم طلعونا من الساعه 6
الصبع مك تكنا اوع ما قالوا لنا البسوا
وهيك واستنينا هم و طلعونا كيف طلعو قلت
لي انه صار اطلاق ماته ه صحيح هذا لما
وصلنا عند معبر رفح شلونا الله يعزك اللي
في رجلينا وقالوا لنا ارجله ودونا على على
ممار مش هو الصح قعدوا تخ تخوا علينا كان
ساعتها معنا شباب كمان معتقلين طلعوهم
فصاروا يطخ علينا صنا نجري بهال صاروا
يقولنا اسر عسر ما يسرح نطخ عليه صاروا
يطخ واحنا ننا نجري لحد ما شفنا الصليب
طيب عائلتك عرفت انكم طلعتوا ولا حدا لا
اللي اللي كان يسمعنا كان يسمعنا 200
قتلونا ما كانوش يعرفونا 50 يوم ما كانوش
يعرفوا علينا ولا حاجه لح ولحتى الان انا
الاسيره جهان فيصل موسى تم اعتقالي من قبل
الاحتلال لمده 50 يوم ورسالتي لاولادي
ولاهلي انهم يتواصلوا ويعرفوا عني اي خبر
انا لس عايشه رسالتي لكل الاسلات بالافراج
ان شاء الله عن قريب ورسالتي لاولادي انا
بحبكم كثير ويا رب نجتمع عن قريب يا
رب